Republican senator Susan Collins
remembers mr. Bush as a compassionate
leader Collins became close friends with
the former president and first lady more
than 20 years ago back in 1994 when I
was running for governor of Maine I had
just won an eight-way Republican primary
and I got a call from President and mrs.
Bush inviting me to have lunch with them
at Kennebunkport at walkers point well
you can imagine how absolutely thrilled
that I was and they were always so kind
to me my hope is that people will
reflect on his legacy on his grace his
dignity on his accomplishments and that
it will inspire people to try to find
common ground and to put an end to the
polarization and divisiveness that is so
terrible for our country and for our
government right now and Collins says
she was touched that the former
president's final tweet praised her
courage and her leadership and John as
much as the president loved Maine you
can't overstate how much he loved the
city of Houston he moved here in 1959
alongside his young family and he was
interviewed by a local reporter a few
years back and was asked do you consider
yourself a Houstonian to which he
replied I don't want to be less than
kind but that's a dumb question where he
made his place in the world he had many
friends in Houston Connecticut
Washington Maine and the country today
bianna thank you